[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
legault naïm qui est là depuis combien
d'années dans touche pas à mon poste 4
ou 5 6 1 sur les quatre ou cinq saisons
sans déconner je joue ça que ce sont vos
valérie bénaïm qui nous a fait une petit
résumé ar 2 votre début d'année et juste
après il y aura les notes bien sûr des
téléspectateurs les notes autour de la
table combien vaut valérie bénaïm
aujourd'hui at elle réussi son début de
saison yann vos valérie bénaïm c'est
elle malheureusement gaufres et vous
allez nous dire dans un instant soyez
francs même si c'est votre ami car
valérie même si vous êtes sévère restera
toujours votre ami enfin pas pour tout
le monde passe et c'est parti regardez
valérie bénaïm dans touche pas à mon
poste
[Applaudissements]
l'avenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas non plus dire que regarder
ça prend du plaisir c'est tout on n'en
prend jamais dans la vie mon chéri mois
[Applaudissements]
elle a découpé on est le petit fils
gargarise know it is it
on se fait et ça fait plaisir que tu me
demandes c'est fou bref il montre des
gens maintenant on sait qu'ils baissent
et patrick sébastien
et en effet signé valérie bénaïm mon ami
vous savez que c'est mon ami et on va
donner des notes à valérie bénaïm on va
démarrer par mme isabelle morini-bosc
votre note et d'attraper prestation sans
valeur et ben ali près elle est belle
elle est mignonne c'est une bien gentil
personnes voilà les bleus remarqué
quelqu'un de santé derrière elle était
complètement largués mais bon c'est une
bien jolie personne et veut m'acheter
qu'elle a exactement les mêmes qualités
physiques psychiques et intellectuel que
l'année dernière avec des amis encore
plus étayée des fois plus tranché donc
moi c'était très bien l'année dernière
c'est encore mieux cette année moi j'ai
mis 9 neuf en valais on rappelle entre 0
et 2 de moyenne c'est l'exclusion
immédiate doit être un que c'est
l'avertissement si ce qui a eu un
capucines à billère 6,8 encouragements
et entre 9 et 10 félicitations estelle
denis la note pour valérie wenning moi
j'ai mis sept
je trouve formidable parce que elle est
toujours d'humeur égale et toujours de
bonne humeur et rigoles à tous vos
blagues jamais mais c'est vrai qu'on
s'est tous jeunesse à brader sale blague
ça s'appelle focus
bah oui et c'est un exemplaire et les
voilà c'est c'est vraiment une fille qui
sait défendre et c'est après ce que je
lui reproche c'est quand même que quand
on déjà dans son dos et ballon sur tout
le monde est là jamais ça s'est un peu
de raison de le dire mais c'est pour ça
ne m'enlève je relève de points valence
et mansoura gentiment et ballan ou
gentiment n'allait plus le méchant de
cons plateau en plateau est trop gentil
et à gagnerait parfois à peut-être
piquer un petit peu plus d'accord a
musclé son jeu
l'un des exemples d'accord je relève
encore un point parce qu'elle met à nu
les trois fois de suite un déjeuner bien
donc cette peau 7 sur 10 po assez gênant
on à emilie lopez la rédactrice en chef
en plus de touche pas à mon poste donc
vous êtes en relation avec elle même en
dehors de l'émission combien vous lui
mettez d'abord l'appréciation et vous
nous donner la note après alors au delà
du fait que valérie est une amie
extraordinaire elle est l'une de celles
qui travaillent le plus dans l'émission
elle fait pas arrivé car on vous dira
comme les autres footeux rien
elle prend des notes elle propose des
choses et surtout cette année j'ai
l'impression que elle y va un peu plus
terre que ce soit en plateau ou en
dehors
elle ose dire à ses petits camarades
comme ça va pas et moi j'ai envie
qu'elle continue comme ça qu'elles
prennent de l'assurance et qu'elle
continue justement à dire tous les
choses et pour sa jumelle les
encouragements parce que j'adore la
valérie benaïm de 2017 et gmail 6,7 me
cissé mais c'est son nez pour valérie on
va avoir la note tout de suite de daniel
mot est d'abord l'appréciation alors la
précession alors je commence par les
reproches valérie elle a été une élève
instable pendant longtemps elle a
beaucoup papillonner dans ses jeunes
années christophe dechavanne thomas
hugues stéphane bern frédéric joly
guillaume durand arthur cauet alexandre
debanne laurent ruquier quelle gourmande
valérie voulez vous les fans et tout ça
me va j'aime bien les gars voilà
maintenant stabilité avec cyril donc
c'est pas mal alors très bons élèves en
français elle a eu son diplôme de
l'école supérieure de journalisme paris
et surtout j'avais adoré son roman la
rose 200 grammes mais alors sentir
proche ça fait 12 ans j'attends le
deuxième un peu paresseuse parce que
j'attends toujours donc je me remette à
l'écriture et voilà c'est pour ça que
j'ai mis 5 comprenant ne pas les révéler
attention on a maintenant la note de
benjamines castagneux castel bé alors
pour valérie les bons camarades à les
cultiver l intelligente elle a plus de
23 ans de métier elle a surtout réussi à
mettre son expérience professionnelle au
service d'une équipe d'une émission je
laime d'amour et je vais me
les ponotes de très bonnes notes on
valérie bénaïm valérie bénaïm ça se
passe bien pour la cei c'est quand on
tient pour l'instant avec pour l'instant
ça va mais je crains le pit vous cache
pas que j'ai laissé les plus sévères
pour la légère laisse guère viralement
sévère manas aussi se doutera tient et
on va voir la vie de gameplay qui le
jeune animateur de l'émission c'est vrai
et on aime beaucoup guillaume donc
guillaume parce que c'est un modèle pour
vous valez révélé c'est un modèle à les
gentils elle est douce là les yeux qui
pétillent etc
mais je lui mets 1 1 pourquoi je suis
très mec c est ce qu elle m'a mentir
jour elle m'a promis de m'offrir une
montre par un pote et alors je suis très
vite ça m'a fait choisir le catalogue et
m'a dit enquête j'ai un copain il va
t'offrir un truc ça fait plaisir et
c'est michel mellenotte le travail
bientôt les toilettes et je m'aperçois
de quoi que mokhtar à la montre que j'ai
commandé depuis quelques semaines au
poignet va bien sûr c'est vrai on passe
assez c'est assez voilà sérieusement
franchement sérieusement dans ces
rivières griffe ou non en vrai
sérieusement voulu mettre 1,8
mais pourquoi parce que elle est hyper
accueillante et bosse bien que je les ai
vus j'ai vu sur ses calepins et prépare
l'émission voit qu'elle est sérieuse etc
et voilà donc voilà huit pour guillaume
ponctue une bonne capucine haddad
pour valérie donc toujours positive
toujours sourire c'est un vrai petit
rayon de soleil dans l'émission c'est un
peu ma maman autour de la table et
beaucoup de gens ça va lui faire plaisir
beaucoup de gens qui se reconnaît son
valérie quand je suis dans la rue c'est
tout en aval et riche l'adorent elle est
trop gentille chez voici en revanche il
ya quand même quelque chose qui a fait
perdre des points pour ma note finale je
trouve qu'il faut que tu prennes
confiance en toi tu casses souvent
derrière des gros des gros chemise ou
des pantalons alors que nombre des
chemises très large alors arrêt
magnifique était hyper sexy et je trouve
que malheureusement tu te met pas assez
en valeur et c'est important pour les
missions courtes il faut que je me mette
dominé je suis plutôt non pas des
minijupes mais quand elle était belle en
fait tu étais vraiment belle femme et je
trouve ça dommage que parfois et ben tu
te caches parce que peut-être que t'as
pas trop confiance en soi est la mission
s'est pas séparé attention
on va voir maintenant la note et
l'appréciation de gilles verdez à hier
fernand vallet révéler h 15 valérie vous
me surprenez dont la première fois le
tout l'histoire ne touche pas à mon
poste cette saison vous avez dit du mal
d'une émission c'était top chef et pour
moi c'est votre premier pas de
l'hypocrisie totale vers l'honnêteté et
ça franchement je voulais le saluer par
un sublime 3 vous mettez trois avaler
les mélèzes
mais d'après le sun a dit une de ses
meilleures notes parce que ces choix que
ces quatre le plafond moi j'allais me
aka capucines à la bruyère ou 2 2 je
crois de 1 3 2 par gentillesse deux
parties est d'accord il donc vous mettez
trois vallées révélé oui voilà vous la
couler 1000 kw à vous mais je trouve que
franchement c'est quoi ces défauts c'est
une hypocrite mais total c'est
incroyable on ne dit jamais ce qu'elle
pense on n'en peut plus mais quand vous
avez des qualités à à fall est maximisée
elle ne pourra très flamboyant comme
élément de séduction quasi animale alors
qu'on vienne le piquet détient plein
versées mais en fait c'est d'arrêter
avec jacques magnifique oui jean louis
leroy dit une fois de plus c'est l'autre
m'a dit oui
matthieu delormeau à merde in aménas
bénin bénin
c'est vrai que les qualités mme abena la
plus grande qualité ton plus grand
talent c'est d'être assise à côté de moi
pour le reste puisqu'on a passé le
positif des abymes abena sont comme tes
cheveux après un brushing lisse
voilà je te le dis c'est beau ça c'est
beau merci beaucoup
j'ai écrit j'ai pris des salariés des
laboratoires garnier non tu me fais
penser un peu aux artichauts mme abena
mais pourquoi là on adore mais ça n'a
pas beaucoup de goût permettait non mais
si intéressant c'est que par exemple moi
je parle des émissions que j'ai vu alors
que toi tu fais ça
[Applaudissements]
non madame à mama et oui et il lui reste
peu de voir je peux vous dire beaucoup
l'esprit direct et bonne animatrice mme
abena une bonne année matisse mais c'est
l'école des fans que tu aurais dû
présenter tout le monde gagne tout le
temps avec toi voilà tu es me jacques
martin il est allongé sous la menace du
matin la place aux côtés de classe peut
répondre et ce que je parlais à son
processeur non mais alors ça m'a alors
je veux pas oui pardon
voilà non mais c'est vrai pour moi
d'accord l'apéro et aux quelques même
terminé on répète que la personne quand
même là alors c'est pas ce que tu pense
donc on sait pas je rejoins gilles là
dessus d'ailleurs je t'ai déjà
interpellé là-dessus l'année dernière
bénard on sait pas a ajouté l'espagnol à
genté marocaines ont été fort qu'on sait
pas où te situer ni toi ni dans
l'émission ça c'est c'est un vrai souci
donc pour tous et put alors voilà vous
allez donner votre note et bien d'autres
choses est très important à la
génériques et vous allez lire le chou a
besoin d'autre chose
eh ben vous allez tirer quand vous est
imparti méchante normal dernière chose
mais n'a la seule fois cette année où tu
as dû prendre te d'ivoire un avis
tranché prendre une décision c'était
pour les élections et a choisi gilles
verdez même quand il faut choisir tes à
côté ma chérie non je choisis celui qui
a gagné c'est au nom quand même à bas
donc on en sait encore plus douala
tuvalu noté de la réussite et de la
victoire même pas du goût des jeunes
gens pensent comme moi alors
mathieu c'est bath a battu c'est quoi je
regrettais ma note à risque du coup
comme derrière tu es ma voisine et que
voilà tu es quand même
souriante sympathique et jolie voilà je
t'ai mis un beau 4 oh la la
ah oui comme r4 et vous avez vous
regretté votre note non mais trois et
demi aurait pu le faire déjà est-ce que
vous avez quelque chose à dire avant de
voir la note des internautes non je vous
laisse vous pour vous vous avez fait un
très bon début d'année
si je suis contente d'être en tant cette
équipe prétentieux en plus je suis
contente de m'investir dans cette
émission est de travailler avec des gens
de valeur pour certains
on va voir tout de suite
la noc les internautes bien entendu la
note des téléspectateurs ou lors la
twittosphère 2,5 excellente note valérie
bénaïm à 6,9 sur 10 vous allez donc les
encouragements valeur
le soir